[音楽]
[拍手]
はい
三宅と申します
普段は
ゲーム会社で
モンスターの人工知能を作っております
皆さんが
ゲームの中では出会うモンスターが
いろいろ考えたり感じたりするんですね
そういう中の人工
知能を作ってもう十何年になります
ちょっと変わった仕事ですよね
モンスターというのは普通
存在しない
現実には存在しないものですのでその人工
知能を作るという仕事が
本当にあるのか
本当にありますね
毎日のようにこのゲームのモンスターは
こう作ればいいんじゃないか
こう考えてほしいとかこう考えてこういう
ふうに振る舞ってほしいとかそういうこと
を考えています
皆さんは
知能について考えたことは
ございますでしょうか
僕は本当に毎日
考えています
いつぐらいから考えて
本当に中学生の頃から
ずっと考えています
中学2年生でよく考えるような
生きるってどういうことだろう
知能って何だろうあるいは
我々が死ぬ時に
失われるものは一体何だろうと
知能っていうのが失われるとしたら一体
それは何だったんだろうまあそういうこと
をずっと考えながら
研究してきました
ですので
モンスターを作るということは
僕にとって
知能とは何かそういうことを探求する一環
でもあるんです
しかし一般に人工知能と言った時にあれ
それって数学とか
科学とか
高額の話なんじゃないのかと思われるかも
しれません
実際
人工知能の中身というのは
プログラムで書かれておりますのであれ
それってなんか哲学とか
心理学とかその関係ないんじゃないかと
そう思われる方もおられるかもしれません
しかしそうではありません
人工知能を作るというのは
電子レンジを作ったりエレベーターを作っ
たりパソコンを作ったりするのとちょっと
違うところがあるんですねそれは
知能を作る
生きているものを作るということなんです
ね
しかしよく考えてみてください
そもそも
知能とは何でしょうか
人類が3000年間いやもっと長い間
我々とは何者なのかというのをずっと考え
てきました
しかしその答えはまだ見つかっていません
ですからこの
世の中の誰も
知能とは何かについて
完璧な答えを出すことは出せる人はいない
のであります
だとしたら人工知能を作るというのは何か
とても検討外れなような気がします
実際人工知能を作る人が知能について完璧
に知っていくとはまずありえません
誰も知らないからですでも人工知能という
のはとりあえず作りながら
知能というのを探求してみようと
僕自身もそうであります
僕自身はもともと
文学青年で中学や高校の方は
文学
特に
ヨーロッパの
ドイツ文学やフランス文学そしてロシア
文学そして
デカルト
現したいとか
そういう哲学書にまみれて
本を
本当に読みまくっていました
ところがそういうものを読みすぎまして
中毒になってしまって
本が読めなくなってしまった時期があった
んですね
本当に文字が
読めなくなってしまって読みすぎて
そして理系に行くというちょっと変わった
手であります
ちょうど大学に入った頃に本当に皆さん
シラバスとね
配りますよねあれが読めないですもう文字
が文字を見ると気持ちが悪くなってしまっ
てですので数学をやることになりますね
数学実はあまり読まなくても
自分で考えればできますのでただ
僕はですね昔から理系とか文系とかそう
いう分類自体がおかしいと思ってたんです
ね
僕は全部やりたいと
哲学もやりたいし文学部屋に対し数学も
物理学も高額もやりたいんだと
結局全部やることになるんですが
入学するときはどれかを選ばなきゃいけ
ないとっても窮屈だったんですねしかし
人工知能というのは実はそれを全部使って
やる学問なんですねですから
実は
知能というものを探求する中には人間の
すべての知識を同意しなければならないと
いうところがあります
つまり知能について定義できないから人工
知能を作れないのではなくて
作りながら
知能というものを探求すればいいんだと
その時に
我々が持っているすべての知識すべての
経験をそこに注ぎ込むことができこれまで
僕が
悩んだり考えたり
泣いたりは見えたりしてきた全部人工知能
に注ぎ込むことができるんですねこの時に
モンスターはないいただいとかこの時に
モンスターは叫んだらいいとかこういう
感情じゃないかとかまるで作品を作るよう
に人工知能を作るというところが
素晴らしいところなのであります
では人間の定義とは何でしょうか
知能の定義とは何でしょうか
本当にこれを僕は知りたいと思っています
しかしその道はとても
険しいそれを研究するのはいわゆる
哲学という学問であります
哲学という学問は
正直言うとあまり人気がないかもしれませ
ん最近は
文系がいらないとかなんかそういう批判も
ですね
強くてところが
哲学なしには何も進むことができないと僕
は思っています
人工知能においても人工知能の基礎は
哲学にあると思っています
それはどういうことかを今日お話ししたい
と思っています
さて皆さんが
身の回りで最も良く接する人工知能は
いわゆるルールベースタイプと呼ばれてい
ます
ゲームでもよく使います
例えば
駅案内の受付ロボットに
渋谷駅はどちらですかというと
山手に乗って方向と教えてくれます
あるいは
顔認証されるとあなたなら顔パスあなたは
通行禁止みたいなこれもルールでできて
いるわけですねそして
台湾や
おはようって話しかけるとおはようござい
ますと帰ってくるあれもまあルールベース
の一つなんですね
でこういったルールベースは本当に人工
知事の60年以上の歴史の中で最初の頃
から作られてきました
いろんな人工知能がこういったルール
ベース作られていって最初は数十
30年前は
数百そして今は
数十万
数百万のルールで人工知能ができています
ディープラーニングも一見ルールに見え
ませんか
意思決定に使う場合は実はあれは
数百万あるいは数千万のルールに還元する
ことも可能です
さてそういった人工知能はどんどん
どんどん賢くなっています
囲碁だって
将棋だってチェスだってもう人間は
叶いません
しかしどんどんどんどん賢くしていくこと
が人工知能なのでしょうか
そういった人工知能に
皆さんは出会いたいと思うでしょうか
確かに最初はそういう人工知能に出会って
みたいと思うかもしれません
しかしそれで十分でしょうか
それは
我々と同じように
希望したり
泣いたりは見えたり
悲しんだり喜んだりそういうことができる
わけではないのです
ただ温められた規則を
忠実に従っている人間にもそういう部分は
確かにありますこのツール度を守ったり
マナーを守ったりいろんな世間言いつきを
守ったりそういうことは確かに
ルールベースでありますがそれは人間の一
つの面にすぎません
人間というのはもっと深くて
混沌としていてそして
同時に
非常に
活発に
発展していくものであります
やはり人工知能においてもそういった
精神活動を持つ
感情を持つ
やあるいは
身体を持つそういった生きている人工知能
に僕は会いたいと思っています
普段モンスターを作る時もやはりそう思っ
ています
ユーザーの皆さんにどういうモンスターに
会ってほしいかと言いますと
単に
賢く考える人工知能にあってほしいわけで
はありません
やはり中身があって
その世界に
きちんと根付いていってそして
モンスターたちもいろんな生活があって
まあ勇者が来たら戦わないかなとか
ちょっと今日はめんどくさいけど
戦ってやるかとかああ終わった戦って
よかった温泉でも行くかとかまあそういう
風にですね
生き生きとした
生活をするような人工知能を僕は作りたい
と思っているわけであります
というのでよく変わり者と言われるわけで
あります
さてこれまぁ哲学というのを考えてみたい
と思います
哲学というのはもちろん
僕もこの校舎で学んでおりましたので
大きな
図書館でたくさんの哲学賞を見ました
しかし
哲学というのは
知識のことではありません
まあ哲学の外といえば
プラタンと皆さん倫理の需要とかで1回は
顔を見たことがあると思います
でプラトンはこういうことを言うんですね
人間というのは
狭い洞窟の中で
影をずっと見ているような存在なんだと
つまり
その外には本当の世界があるのに
いつまでも
閉じこもって
物事の本質の鍵しか見えていない
では哲学とは何かと言いますとそういった
人間をその洞窟から解き放って
本当の真実に向かい合わせると
本当のもの
実在と向き合わせるものだと
僕は解釈つまり
哲学というのは
プラットにとって開放であったわけであり
ます
で解放であると同時に
次の景色を見えてくると
古い考えを打ち破り
新しい場所に導く
その繰り返しが
哲学のようになります
つまり哲学とは
創造と破壊なのであります
さて人工知能とは何でしょうか
今人工知能と呼ばれた全ての思考マシンで
あります
その基礎になったのは
デカルト近代哲学を作った
デカルトの考えに基づいていますつまり
デカルトはすごく要約しますと人間とは
考える存在である
想定器ですとすると人工知能もやっぱり
考える存在なんでというふうに思い込んで
作ってきたのがこの
70年の人工知能の歴史なのであります
しかしさっき申し上げてましたように人間
は考える存在だけではありません
希望したり不安になったりあるいは心配事
をしたり何か神経質になったりそういった
いろんな精神活動をします
そうすると
[音楽]
ふさえるという人は
デカルトの哲学がちょっと狭いんだと人間
は
世界へ向かう意識であるとこの指向性と
言いますけどそういったいろんな精神活動
を持って人工知能を作りましょうというの
が
現象学的人工知能と
デカレートちょっと広がったわけですね
さらに
次にウィンナーでしたサイパンにティクス
ということです人間というのは
環境とともにあります
環境に対して働きかけでその
フィードバックを得てその無限のループの
中を循環しているのだとそうWINNER
はありますそうすると人工知能も世界と
連動した運動だというふうに
定義することができるわけであります
さてここで個々の哲学者の考えが重要な
わけではありません
重要なのは最初に申し上げましたように
哲学というのは開放であるということです
つまり
狭い考えから
順番により広い考えになってきます
そして人工知能にとって哲学というのは
土台を与えるものですどんな建物にも土台
が必要ですその土台が広ければ広いほど
より高い建物を作ることができます
すなわち人工知能のを良い人工知能を作る
ためには
深い哲学的思想が必要になるとそういう
ことであります
さて最初に申し上げました人工知能とは何
でしょうか
それは
サイエンスや工学だけでありましょうかと
いうことを申し上げましたそれはそうでは
ありません
人工知能の
土台人工知能をよって立つ第一を作るのは
これは
文化系の仕事なのでありますつまり哲学
人文学人間に対する知能に関するあらゆる
知識を動員して
人工知能を支える基礎をより大きな土壌の
もとに作り上げるとその上にプログラムを
書いたりハンダ付けをしたり
シミュレーションしたりするのは
エンジニアインとかサイエンスの仕事なん
ですねつまり人工知能というのはそういっ
た
総合的な
学問なのでありますそして
僕はさらに人工知能を拡張したいと思って
います
今までの考えをさらに超えてより大きな
土台のもとに作りたいその一つの考えが
メタエアでありますこれは
ゲームでは
すでに導入されているかゲームそのものの
人工知能なんですね
プレイヤーが
下手だと思ったら
モンスターの
攻撃をちょっと弱めたい
うまいと思ったら
より強いモンスターを出してあげる
あるいは男女の形をより複雑にするなど
人間を理解して
ゲームを変化させる人工知能です
そうするとこういったものは
現実空間でもやはり応用可能なのです
この東京都全体を滑るような
都市のメタン愛というのを考え事ができ
ます人間の生活を見守って人間の生活の質
を上げていくようなそして実際に刺激さ
れるのは
ロボットやエージェントということになり
ますさらに人間の活動はもはやリアル空間
だけではありません
メタバース空間にも広がっておりこの全域
をカバーして人間を
観察し人間に必要なものを提供するとそう
いった都市のメタリというのを今自分は
取り組んでいます
1つ例を出します
例えば
7にたくさんの仕草さんがいたします
7に行っても鹿の差の全貌をわかることは
できませんただこれがメタバースに
つながっていると全ての
歯科さんの
位置が
メタバス内に同期していれば
メタバス内で
現実の
鹿の様子を
把握することができるわけです
そういうふうに
現実とメタバースをつないことによって
全体
デジタル空間と現実空間にまたがったよう
な人工知能を作ることができます
これが僕が思うこれからの人工知能ある
場合はスマートCと呼ばれある場合はメタ
バーストと呼ばれるようなものであります
さてまとめますといろんな
学問というものは人間や世界を分解して
分類することで行われてきましたところが
人工知能というのはそういった分解した
知能をもう一度統合して一つの人工知能を
作るというものであります
学問は世界と人間を分類分解してきました
人工知事はそれらの知識を統合して人間や
世界を再現しようとすることです
世界を分解して人間の知識を得てきたこれ
は学ぶということです
しかし作ることの前では連携とか文系と
いう区分はありません
人間が獲得した知識から再び世界を
創り上げるのが人工知能とそういう学問で
ありますのでこれらは
すべての
学問をする人に
関連のある
事業なのでありますこれから皆さんと
新しい未来を作っていければいいと考えて
おりますありがとうございました
[拍手]